voici maintenant
bernard frank leprou ce des 80 tel qu'on
l'a décrit du côté de chardonne
interview push d'express tu veux que je
te dise tu m'épates dans la france
bonsoir bonsoir kansai et franck depuis
introuvable puisque flammarion réédite
la géographie universelle l'illusion
comique et après les rails et d'autres
oui c'est au badhus vous nous trouverez
ça tu es aux bains douches l'année
dernière très difficile de le distinguer
les différences c'est pas encore la
pléiade et bien c'est une question que
vous avez posé justement six autres
sites préférés si je la préférais être
édité la pléiade cellule choix s'il est
ce un choix de stendhal et au fond d'eux
mêmes c'est peut-être plus lisible
encore flammarion que
ouais j'ai tu disais dans un siècle
débordés que la pléiade c'était le poche
des riches
oui et maintenant ça me manque parce que
comme j'ai toujours pas de bibliothèque
parce que je déménage trop souvent et on
sent ce d'un appartement à l'eau ça me
manque
peut-être que je vais choisir la paix
yann la veille à bouquin qui est très
très bien aussi il ya une sorte de
concurrence qui a coûté 1 peut-être
hadopi des démocratique plus ça tient
mieux peut-être les tuent des ménages
mais pour tenter une vie très rangée
maintenant non mais j'ai toujours eu une
vie très roger mélasse et de petite
fille une femme la plus de whisky du
perrier dans un le plus de whisky c'est
du moins la télé c'est n'ose pas mater
les opposants à la tht et leurs épouses
un whisky c'est plutôt l'épreuve du
magal l'himalaya pour moi c'est c'est de
faire de la télé sauf sur wii ce qui
enterre publié six livres de 53 à 58
après un tous les dix ans quoi il ya une
série débordé il ya eu il ya eu seul
alors ça étonne beaucoup les gens
pourtant dans les reins beaurieux disais
qu'est-ce qu'on peut offrir à ses
lecteurs après le deuxième livre quelle
salade on peut leur vendre il faut
garder des surprises pour la
cinquantaine
finalement les gens qui avaient lu les
rats à l'époque aurait dû être prévenu
pourquoi tout le monde s'en est
tellement étonné alors que toi tu tues
avait annoncé la couleur dès le départ
oui remarque il ya juillet réglages qui
disait que france des quelques a écrit
un livre
la premier league on pensait qu'ils
avaient des droits pour
pour en écrire deux mois 4,6 et fit
l'odyssée pas s'arrêter je trouve ça pas
plus mal d'écrire tout haut oui enfin tu
écris pour le monde toute façon c'est
comme si tu remettait un chapitre à
temps at-on éditeurs toutes les semaines
ça te prend du temps de faire cette
chronique du monde reprend quand même
temps par semaine
eh bien je mets mais le samedi après
midi
je dors dessus un peu à la méthode elle
est la maigret et puis le dimanche
c'est un monde débarrassé des miasmes de
la semaine et le dimanche alors je me
laisse à l'herbe le vent à cette heure
un moment il y avait une à la télévision
il y avait un truc là j'ai ce couple
pour l'amour du risque
ouais eh bien je commence à verser a
cure il fait du bien cela oui on va leur
dire de leur passé alors je me souviens
d'un article de 2,9 dans le quotidien de
paris et tu lui avait répondu que
j'avais pris ligne par ligne paragraphe
par paragraphe qu'il avait répandu et à
un moment tu lui disait que finalement
c'était beaucoup plus dur d'être guidé
carc bernard frank parce que c'était
plus dur d'avoir de l'intelligence que
du talent et que lui avait su trouver
avait eu l'intelligence vie des quarts
de finale ment trouver un public énorme
à chaque bouquin en tout cas c'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire que y'a
pas d'écrivain méprisable
voilà je pense que sa demande autant de
mal d'écrire de mauvais livres écrits en
soi disant bons alors chardonne tu à
comparer à proust
alors on va te faire un petit à petit et
ça je dis oui oui je fais ce que tu veux
je dis rien tu vas voir pourquoi je te
dis ça c'est pas ça bien innocent c'est
qu'on va te faire un petit questionnaire
de proust qui est pas de trousse
d'ailleurs comme tu le sais peut-être
est un jeu de société qui datent du 19e
siècle
si je te dis par exemple bernard frank
c'est quoi pour toi le compte de la
misère la télévision c'est pas faux pour
quelle faute à tulle plus d'un d'urgence
or pour la gourmandise des héros de
romans préférés
j'ai longtemps hésité balancé entre
ashley et rhett butler
ouais et puis
c'est pas je peux on a des rounds roman
préféré jusqu'à 14 ans temps personnages
historiques favori henri iii pourquoi ne
pas hésiter à droite et les genres il
était contre eux j'aimais bien je l'aimé
bien en dessous de ses ennemis qui
détestait il détestait les guides je
détestais tous et tous ses détracteurs à
kayes bourguignonne tous les ans boulet
son occupation préférée écrire
ton principal trait de caractère à ton
avis
l'endurance c'est moi qu'on puisse en
dire
ce que tu apprécies le plus chez tes
amis la télé chance
ces kits et à me bats toi c'est très
sympa merci beaucoup bernard ton
principal défaut le doute et la vanité
et ça c'est le défaut de l'écrivain
dante choix comment tu aimerais mourir
paisiblement en quoi je n'entends pas
venir ne m'ont pas vision est là est un
peu lourd de cuvées louise c35 jean
flare un peu cancéreux
il y en a beaucoup trop de lyon
tentons baume et voilà d'accord l'état
présent de ton esprit là maintenant
assez calme oui apparemment ce n'est
qu'un moment à passer
les corrections de ne rien rater de
finale andy tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus